protesters outside the Ukrainian
president's office in the capital Kiev
they're angry about an agreement with
Kremlin backed separatists in eastern
Ukraine which allows for elections in
legislated territory they say it amounts
to capitulation to Russia the war has
been going on in Ukraine's East for
almost five years Ukrainian soldiers
died there shed their blood and
volunteers provide aid the community
cares about Ukrainian independence and
then in one day all of these efforts are
broken by a statement of capitulation by
the presidential office the agreement
between the Ukrainian government Kremlin
backed separatists Russia and European
monitors was signed in the Belarusian
capital Minsk separatists negotiators
say it's an important first step to end
the fighting between separatists and
Ukrainian government forces that began
after Russian forces seized and annexed
the Crimean Peninsula from Ukraine in
2014 you know in process it's a starting
point where we begin the process of
creating the conditions for a political
resettlement first of all it means a
change in the Ukrainian Constitution and
the adoption of a special law about the
election at least 13,000 people have
been killed in fighting over the last
five years Ukraine's recently elected
president Vladimir's olenski wants to
revive peace negotiations with Russia
but analysts say this deal may
consolidate demands by separatists for
greater autonomy so you really can't
have free and fair elections and used to
create under current conditions and
that's exactly what Moscow wants it
wants to use this process with what it
considers a weak Ukrainian president
who's growing more and more isolated
from his international partners in the
West to try to take advantage at a very
decisive moment and solidify the
Kremlin's gains on the ground
zalinsky says elections will be held
only when ukraine regains control of all
its borders with Russia was nature an
oven this means they're journalists and
members of the audience that there will
be no election under the gun and there
can't be any
but these protesters fear zalenski has
made too many concessions already and a
warning that Russia will be a tough
negotiating partner in any future talks
to end fighting in eastern Ukraine
Victoria Gaytan be al-jazeera